9 heures c'est l'ouverture des portes
chez le disquaire aux 33 tours à
montréal 3h20 qu'importe la tente les
passionnés de disques vinyles ont
profité de la journée des disquaires
pour mettre la main sur des albums rares
bayeux prend 4 600 sorties de disques
qui sortent exclusivement sur vinyle
pour cette journée si donc les one shot
cette fête de la musique des îles depuis
2008 à faire la promotion des disquaires
indépendants qui sont de moins en moins
nombreux avec la vente de la musique en
ligne
parce que c'est correct le streaming on
est vraiment d'accord avec ce qu'on
m'écoute ou sans suivi mais non je pense
que le vinyle je pourrais me conforte
qui reviennent une passion qui prend de
l'ampleur selon le disquaire c'est des
collectionneurs des mélomanes des
spéculateurs des gens qui veulent
acheter pour peut-être à vendre plus
tard ce que des choses tu auras de plus
en plus d'artistes québécois participent
à cette journée des disquaires
il ya une éducation autour de ça aussi
faux faux le faux faut le montrer seront
plus jeunes 7 et regarde l'objet regarde
les crédits qui a travaillé sur album là
parce que l'accès à la musique sur
internet est tellement facile avec le
streaming c'est à coup de dizaines de
disques que les clients ont dévalisé le
magasin est ce que vous avez acheté
j'ai pas juste pour moi j'ai acheté ce
pour des amis mais je n'achète peut-être
une journée très lucrative pour les
propriétaires c'est le noël des
disquaires qu'on peut dire parce que
c'est la journée la plus occupée de
l'année
c'est tout simplement une célébration
musique une toupie de 12 ans qui ne fait
que grandir avant tout pour ses
mélomanes
c'est l'amour de la musique qui les unit
au perso je connais tout le monde ici
avec c'est vraiment c'est comme boire du
bon vieux de choc ici marie josée paquet
comme radio canada montréal